we're ready to go I'm a huge fan of
yours ain't absolutely love you and this
character is cookie and congratulations
on season three how what does it mean
like she is something unique beautiful
fierce crazy what does she mean to you
and to be part of your life in your
career um well she certainly gotten me
the recognition that everybody says I
deserved finally and it's odd because
I've been working for a long time and
you know I've been doing I think great
work yeah but it's just I guess this
character was just such a fun just took
over yeah and she's just become such a
phenomenon that you have to pay
attention mm-hmm
she is a phenomenal yeah you just have
to pay attention so you know it makes it
makes getting movies greenlit or you
know people investing in me doing a film
project makes it my job a little easier
makes my team job a little easier and
cookie has a tendency of getting her way
she's always determined yeah would you
say there's similarities are you a
person that's determined and always
trying to find your way oh absolutely I
wouldn't have gotten this far in the
industry as a mother if I didn't if I
didn't fight for what I thought I
deserved and you know one of the things
that we do have in common we both
studied Electrical Engineering oh really
you probably did much better than I did
finish it finish no I found and did you
fail precalc no way I wasn't supposed to
be doing it I didn't get accepted into a
fine arts high school so when it was
time to go to college I thought I
couldn't act so I just saved my friend
that might one of my best friends at the
time was going to school for electrical
engineering and I was like yeah I'll do
that
nobody because you're Carrie you're
doing the character Karen G Johnson on
here and figures like this it's not a
video
yeah when his sense of humor you get to
do math again right what does this film
mean to you it means that I'm still dumb
when it comes to math they had a
mathematician on set to teach me the
actual equations
I just had to memorize them because he
was trying to break them down and I was
like it sounds like Chinese I don't
understand it so yeah let's just see if
I kind of a actor I really am I still
use my fingers ready to do math with you
right now and you have a memoir coming
out as well
everything that's happening you're
writing a bio you have a bio what is the
one thing people will find out about you
that is just going to be fascinating I
think everything they just don't know
the intricacies of a lot of the stories
that they may have read about in an
interview so it's more in-depth in the
book I don't know what they might find
out that they don't know they already
know cuz I'm on Instagram they know I'm
goofy and silly and love to laugh for a
long time people didn't know that about
me cuz I played all these serious
dramatic roles until social media became
a success and then I'm like you're funny
that tweet was funny and you know it's
interesting how my fans know I'm funny
but yet I still haven't done a comedy
yeah go you know I was from Golden
Globes and I actually got to see you
holding the globe oh really and just
yeah it was you were going to a party
and you were just holding it with a lot
empowerment that moment must have been
spectacular for you it was because you
know I'm never I never said I'm gonna
become an actress because I want to win
awards right that's not even how I think
yeah
but I'm always honored and and so happy
and blessed and thankful and grateful
when I am picked out of pool of
incredible talent and so but I never I
don't put a lot on it because that's not
that trophy's not gonna make or break me
I'm still gonna continue to do the work
I've been doing you know but there's an
appreciation Oh totally totally and I'm
like I said I'm very grateful and just
honored I'm honored because like I said
there are a lot of talented people and
you know what I love about the show is
because you have so many guest
appearances and I know Mariah Carey is
gonna be on season three and I've been
asking everyone this question because
people love cookie and she's one of a
kind yeah who's a bigger diva Mariah
Carey or a cookie Mariah was
very chill to surgery yeah and people
think that we go toe to toe in the show
and we don't she's actually like a
friend of mine a friend of cookies I've
cut friend yeah so there was no no drunk
drama there sorry
how would you describe season three in
one word um season three in one word
compelling compelling oh thank you so
much congratulate thank you